أحد الأمور التي تحدث عنها الرئيس بايدن أيضًا
هو التهديد الذي
تشكله إيران على المنطقة ولكن بين
أعضاء مجلس التعاون الخليجي لا يوجد
الكثير من القواسم المشتركة ، حيث تتخذ الإمارات العربية المتحدة موقفًا مختلفًا تمامًا
يمكنني التحدث نيابة عن دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي لديها موقف موحد  الموقف ويمكنك أن
ترى أن دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في حالة حالة من
الواضح تمامًا أننا نجري مناقشات مع
إيران كما تعلم ، وكذلك الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لذا
فإن أصدقائنا في قطر والكويت ، لذلك نحن
جميعًا بصفتنا مجموعة دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي نتحدث
إلى الإيرانيين لأننا نريد ذلك  حل
خلافاتنا من خلال الحوار ، نأمل
أن يرد الإيرانيون بالمثل
ما قلته للرئيس بايدن
بشأن موقف إسرائيل من ضربة الملاذ الأخير
لإيران
، فلن يكون في مكاني
أن أعلق على مواقف دولة أخرى
يجب أن تكون قد قلت شيئًا
لها.  الرئيس بايدن لأن
سقوط مثل هذا الإجراء من قبل إسرائيل
بدعم من الولايات المتحدة يمكن
أن يكون له تأثير على المملكة العربية السعودية ،
أعني مناقشتنا مع الرئيس بايدن
كراون بري  ركزت مناقشة nce مع الرئيس
على كيفية معالجة
التهديد الإيراني هنا تحدثنا عن أه أولاً
وقبل كل شيء
ولكن أيضًا
وضع
ضغط
كافٍ لتحفيز الإيرانيين على القدوم إلى
طاولة المفاوضات ، ما هو شكل هذا
الضغط
وهذا شيء لا يزال يتعين علينا القيام به
اكتشفوا لأننا لسنا هناك ولكن
ما رأيك في الإغراءات
التي ستجعلها تعمل ،
آمل أن يأخذ الإيرانيون الحوافز التي من شأنها
الاندماج بشكل أفضل في
التعاون الاقتصادي في المنطقة مع
جيرانهم والتي يمكن أن تقدم
فوائد هائلة لـ  من
الواضح أن الشعب الإيراني يجب أن نحمي
أنفسنا وهنا نعمل معنا أه
لبناء قدراتنا وقدرات الآخرين
في المنطقة لبناء قدرتنا
للدفاع عن أنفسنا ضد
عدوان إيراني محتمل
ستذكرون الهجوم على
منشآتنا في  كل هذا يعني
أننا بحاجة إلى بناء
موقف دفاعي قوي
وسمعنا التزامًا  الرئيس الروماني بايدن أه إلى
دفاع قوي عن المملكة وما
الذي يبدو عليه ذلك جسديًا عندما
يقول إنه سيعطيك دعمًا قويًا
وقوة بالطبع هذه مجموعة
واسعة جدًا من الأنشطة التي
تعزز قدرتنا على مكافحة ميسو
أقرب
إلى الجيش الأمريكي للتدخل على سبيل المثال
الأسلحة تتدفق إلى اليمن